or so we know a lot of people wanted me
to make a spoiler filled review for The
Hobbit and unexpected journey and I'll
try to incorporate that in this one but
my main motivation for doing this video
as I saw the Hobbit an unexpected
journey in 24 frames a second which is
the normal cinematic format and I
thought to myself all right if this is
different enough I will do a video
talking about how it's different now so
here I am making a video about it so by
implication you already know that I
really felt like it was a different
experience now I have to illustrate I
stand by my initial review of the movie
and for those of you who are apparently
under the impression that the rating I
would buy the movie on blu-ray is a bad
or negative rating that is the second
highest rating I can give a movie it's
not like I called the movie a piece of
[ __ ] I understand most of you understand
this but after seeing it in 24 frames a
second I have to illustrate a few more
points and that is that sadly the 48
frames a second format that Peter
Jackson filmed the movie in does
compromise the experience I think it's a
really cool technological leap that he's
making but in the end it does take you
out of the movie and here's why because
we are human beings we're creatures of
habit we are used to 24 frames a second
for cinema that's the format that's been
around forever so when you go okay
here's a new format and it looks
completely different it jars people's
minds I move he's supposed to be
immersive you know you're in the movie
you're up in the tower with John McClane
you're in middle-earth with the
fellowship in this case you should feel
like you're in middle-earth with the
dwarves but what it did for me and I
have to assume it did for a lot of
people giving it the rating on Rotten
Tomatoes is surprisingly low is that it
took them out of the movie from me I
felt like I was someone sitting in the
movie theater watching a movie playing
48 frames a second it's not immersive I
didn't feel like I was in middle-earth
on this adventure which then means slow
moments feel slower long moments feel
longer the irony in the no-win situation
the Kobayashi Maru of it all is that the
format that the Hobbit and unexpected
journey was filmed in to be more
immersive does the exact opposite for
the audience kind of a bummer really
when the 48 frames a second obviously
compromised my experience in a way that
I didn't really understand until I also
saw it in 24 frames a second but after
24 frames a second I was like okay that
was so much more immersive that it was
just a much better experience which is
worth addressing right here and I run my
TV on auto Motion Plus so I get that 120
Hertz 60 frames a second look or looks
like a soap opera for movies i watch it
like that
I think it looks cool I also play PC
games which run at 60 frames a second
but watching a movie like that looks
completely different in my opinion it's
just a different looking thing that you
can't describe but you just have to see
it you'll be like oh that's what Jeremy
was talking about ok filming the movie
in twice the framerate makes the movie
look better but it doesn't necessarily
make the movie better now like I said
before I do find it interesting I want
to see where they take the technology
I'm just saying if you're gonna do a
test run like this don't do it on a
franchise like The Hobbit do it unlike
step-up six or something just see what
people think of it you test the water by
dipping your toe in it you don't jump
off the high dive to see how warm or
cold the water is just saying so I
imagine there are a number of reviewers
out there who watched it in 48 frames a
second or like well I've seen the movie
now I strongly urge everybody to watch
it in 24 frames a second do that before
you give your final thought because it
does absolutely change the experience so
on that let's get to talking about some
of the spoilers in the movie all right
The Hobbit an unexpected journey really
starts out in the Shire or at least you
get a pretty badass prologue with a
bunch of dragons or at least a dragon
but then you're in the Shire and in
homeplace old Bilbo which is funny
because you know in Gandalf so like you
haven't aged a day I don't know he may
have lied to his face a little bit cuz
Ian Holm looks really old I understand
it I'm sure him and Peter Jackson are
friends you could have just had in home
do the voiceover for the prologue and
then had the movie come in 60 years
earlier with Martin Freeman his Bilbo
and started the movie seeing Ian Holm
play Bilbo now makes you go well he's
older now than he was in fellowship with
a ring when this takes place like 30
minutes before Fellowship of the Ring it
just confuses your brain even his hair
looks different like I said before there
are some cameos in the movie where
you're like oh yeah that was a cool
cameo other cameos well I should say
cameo you're like that was kind of
Forrest the forced cameo for me was
Frodo Baggins I liked seeing Frodo
Baggins when he walks out of that room
and he looks over at Bilbo and he smiles
and he shakes his head and he keeps
walking I thought that was gonna be the
end of it and I was fine with that
but the part that irritates me my friend
disagrees with me it's fine because
human beings auld it's just all opinions
secret is out reviewers of the world
just give you their opinions that's
between you and me don't tell anyone but
my Frodo's like oh I'm gonna go surprise
Gandalf by the road and he goes off I
was just like you don't need to stitch
The Hobbit and fellowship with a ring
together down to the minute if I want to
use a douchebag term it just seems
indulge
and it's just kind of what it was for me
and Elijah Wood looks about 40 years old
also I think that pulls me out of it as
well then that dwarves enter Bilbo's
house and they really frustrate him and
actually the build that the Shire built
up in the entire movie the second time
watching it I was like well yeah we're
kind of we are par for the course for
Fellowship of the Ring but when I first
watched Fellowship of the Ring it was in
24 frames a second like my second
viewing of The Hobbit wasn't 48 frames a
second which I was sitting in the
theater going oh I'm a guy in a theater
watching the Shire then that goes on you
see some iconic scenes like the whole
troll scene where they're gonna boil
them or cook them or squash them into
jelly I love that scene because you see
the troll statues in Fellowship of the
Ring so I was looking I was like okay I
want to see if they freeze in the same
position I noticed that one pointing
down props of that and that's what Peter
Jackson's great about those little
details what makes him a badass so
another thing that didn't irritate me
the second time around watching the
Hobbit was radagast the brown
and to be clear for people who thought I
called him the Jar Jar Binks of
middle-earth I did not call him the Jar
Jar Binks of middle-earth what I said
was if people do call him the Jar Jar
Binks of middle-earth I'm not going to
argue them and I still wouldn't because
I'd be like okay I'm able to see your
opinion I can see how you would think
that all I said was I wish they had done
him differently and I still wish they
did him differently however with Gandalf
going he's a very great wizard and him
caring that little Hedgehog of smoke
monster disease from lost or whatever he
did you're like okay yeah he has power
but he's actually in the movie a lot
less than I remember I think it was one
of those scenarios where I was like I
underhyped him to the point where when I
watched the movie again I was like well
it's not as bad as I remember but I said
the last couple hours of this movie are
completely badass for me it was when
they got to Rivendell when they got to
Rivendell to the end of the movie I
loved it all
I love seeing Elrond again which is
funny cuz I hadn't actually seen Gandalf
and Galadriel interact at all this is
the first time in the movies you
actually see that you really get the
sense you're like yeah Galadriel she
really wants to hit that you can see a -
Gandalf with a pipe in his hand and a
leg and the other all ideas comeö to be
I'm just saying it could happen and she
wants it to happen
I like seeing Saruman also cuz at this
point he's good and he doesn't have much
love for radagast the brown either his
consumption of mushroom which it for
nothing else the middle-earth movies as
I'm gonna call them is teaching kids one
thing eat mushrooms you become some
tripping Tweaker hippie in the middle of
the woods smoked some old Toby in one
day you can take out that thing smoked
up kids
cool for a couple reasons one you see
Rivendell again and that's all awesome
you see reoccurring characters and
cameos that's badass but they're also
finding out that the necromancer is
coming back the necromancer for those of
you who do not know is Sauron yeah like
you know big evil of Lord of the Rings
right now all they know is a guy who
calls himself the necromancer is all
hanging out at dull gold or now they got
bigger and better things to do like you
know get a treasure from a dragon
skipping forward a little bit let's talk
about another scene that I felt is the
scene that they could have taken out of
this movie in my review and I was
talking about some scenes that I felt
would have been better left out and then
included in the extended edition of The
Hobbit an unexpected journey this is the
scene I was talking about and that's the
scene when those two big rocks were
kickin the [ __ ] out of each other doing
Rock'em Sock'em rocks I'm fine with the
fact that middle-earth has big mountains
that throw rocks at each other [ __ ] they
have trees that walk and talk yeah they
got mountains this scene was so like
okay we're leaving reven delle big
mountains are kicking the [ __ ] out of
each other and now we're going to rest I
think it would have been better to give
us shorter cuts of the movies so the
general populace can be like okay now
I'm invested with these characters now
I'm into their quest I would like to see
more oh now we have an extended cut I
get to see more but if you just throw
the extended cut at people right off the
bat they're gonna be like it the movie
just feels too long I think if Peter
Jackson had done it that way the Hobbit
and unexpected journey would have been
better received by some people at all
people I get it like there are a lot of
people who are like no it's perfect cool
I'm just saying if you did it that way
that would have been better for a
general populace now when the whole crew
goes into the goblin cave and you have
that one Goblin that sounds just like
Ian McShane but it's really not him I
guess I love this scene simply for what
this was the scene I was talking about
when I was like Gandalf is such a badass
in this movies when they're all there
and they're gonna start kicking the piss
out of the dwarves and that big light
comes out of nowhere just just wipes
everything out initially before it
showed who did it I was like I don't
know who did that I really hope it's
Gandalf sure enough you see is
silhouette with his pointy hat and a
sword in his staff he walks up he's like
pick up your arms I'm like that's why
you're a badass old dude who's awesome
and then after that more excitement
ensues while Bilbo is doing riddles in
the dark with Gollum and this also has
the scene in any of the scenes in this
movie this is the scene where I was like
oh this is seeming that big goblins
there and he's like what are you gonna
do and then Gandalf just slices his
stomach and you see it cut through the
fat me it looks
gie but it looked like it cut through
fat and that's the thing I want to point
out in this movie The Hobbit may have
been written for kids but the movie was
not made for kids come on the movie has
decapitations and a big evil Defiler
holding up a dwarves head his severed
head right there I was like it's not
really made for kids unless kid cartoons
and shows are showing bloody severed
heads in which case where if I'd been
but again the riddles in the dark
segment with Gollum I love this segment
why cuz it get to do golems voice again
oh really you get that emotion you
remember in the Fellowship of the Ring
when Gandalf and Frodo are talking and
Gandalf like Pidgey there's pity that
stayed Boo Boo's heard
I hope they show that in the movie and
they totally do this scene where Bilbo
has sting his sword the golems neck and
Gollum turns around cuz he's invisible
because he can't see him he's just
lookin around you see a tear trickled
down his eye or like oh man II he did
lose his precious if anyone in
middle-earth is more entitled to have
the ring other than Sauron himself
it is Gollum dude had a 500-year
relationship with Batman he's his
precious I seen where he's looking as
reflection he's all like you're like
Bilbo just put on the ring and run dude
you're dead and come on be honest with
yourselves how many people were trying
to figure out the riddles when Gulman
build overdoing the riddles back and
forth come on you know you were I was
[ __ ] and then you think they get to
safety and they're not because the big
evil to fire or cos they're and it was
all cool he's turning pine cones into
grenades and that's badass that's what
Wizards do but this also has one of the
most badass scenes which is
simultaneously one of the scenes that
made me go really and that's the scene
when all the good guys are trapping the
defias there on his warg and he's gonna
wipe everyone out in the trees all
fallen over and then foreigns like you
know what not on my dead awesome warrior
dwarf body who looks like a Klingon cuz
I do and he stands up all epically like
he's gonna face down with him he ends up
whipping it taking a warg pod in the
face it doesn't matter point is this
moment is extremely awesome and for
every badass moment you need a badass
song and the song plays and it's
awesomely epic yet you're like I
recognize that song I've heard it before
in the Lord of the Rings movie the song
that plays in that scene is the
identical song to the scene on
Weathertop and fellowship of the ring
when the nazgûl were closing in on the
it's the same exact song you're like
it's a badass song don't get me wrong
which rhymes and I didn't mean for it
but why didn't Howard sure make an
original badass song for that same just
kind of took me out of it a bit it threw
me off it's like yeah it's cool but why
not an original song we've already
established that that song plays when
evil is closing in on good maybe he
played it to flip it around for The
Hobbit I don't know I love that scene
when Bilbo's talking to Thorin he's like
you're right I think of the Shire I
think of my books I miss them all that's
where I belong at home you don't have a
home because it was taken from you but I
will try to help you get it back if I
can I was like these are the Lord of the
Rings moments right here man
middle-earth brings out of its people in
conclusion watching The Hobbit an
unexpected journey in 24 frames a second
is more immersive than 48 frames a
second which is what 48 frames a second
was designed to be but absolutely is not
let's see where they go with that tech
later on in life for now watch the
Hobbit movies in 24 frames a second
because had I seen it in 24 frames a
second and been fully immersed in the
world of middle-earth I probably would
have given it a higher rating that being
said I stand by my rating and saying
that the things that I had knit dicks
about do stand as nitpicks that I still
have but just less nitpicks but I can't
renege on my rating I do that my
credibility's lost [ __ ] that noise just
take heart and knowing that I absolutely
profess that the hobbit and unexpected
journey is a great movie and the rating
I would buy it on blu-ray is an
extremely positive rating advocating
that I say every one of you should watch
the movie because I don't buy crap on
blu roll I have a couple of guilty
pleasures on blu-ray that's not the
point
so the Hobbit an unexpected journey did
you see it in 48 frames a second or 24
frames a second if you saw it in 48
frames a second you're like watch it in
24 frames a second you'd be surprised
how it makes a difference but whatever
you thought at 24 frames a second or 48
frames a second comment below let me
know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you